okay so yesterday I did a story about
how YouTube is increasingly destroying
independent news and politics channels
and I explained to you that YouTube is
increasingly prioritizing basically just
what makes the money by keeping
advertisers happy and since September
that has not been independent content
like ours it's been instead this legacy
corporate content and I went through
yesterday in much more detail than I
will do today how our portion of videos
that come from what is called the
suggested video feed on YouTube it's an
algorithm that says oh you watched this
piece of video here's other stuff you
might like we used to get 1/3 of our
views from that suggested video
algorithm that has fallen basically by
50% to under 17% so far in June this may
be it seems like a lot maybe it doesn't
but as I said yesterday this is about
half of what we were once getting from
this algorithm and this decline started
right after YouTube announced that in an
effort to crack down on fake news which
may well be a good-faith effort they are
going to back what they consider
authoritative sources and that has
coincided coincidence right with the
decline from 33% of our views coming
from the suggested view of sources to
under 17 percent and this is a massive
blow to our revenue because it
represents a lot of views I mentioned
yesterday and I'm just getting you up to
speed before I give you the new info
about how this is much worse than even I
thought in December we got three and a
half million views just from the
suggested video feed in June we will be
lucky to get a million and a half views
that's a 2 million view shortfall which
is a huge revenue shortfall very very
big I can't tell you how much revenue
that is but if you Google YouTube CPMs
you could probably calculate it for
yourselves and I received a flood of
emails yesterday telling me just how bad
it is and it's actually even worse than
I thought I want to remind you Alexander
wrote to me last week or the week before
and he told me something that's really
odd which was that he had never watched
anything by Joe Rogan on YouTube before
and then I was on Joe Rogan's program on
June 5th and Alexander watched one video
on Joe Rogan's channel my interview with
Joe and the next day every single
recommended video was a Joe Rogan video
despite Alexander having watched my
content on YouTube for years and having
been previously recommended my content
on YouTube I now have even more data
points and it's really bad a lot of
people wrote to me with basically some
version of this email that Lisa wrote to
me Lisa wrote to me yesterday and said
hey David just listen to the podcast
where you spoke about the new algorithm
for YouTube I noticed last week that you
were no longer on my home page of
YouTube and I had to search for you I
have a subscription so you did turn up
on the subscription page I've also
noticed that the majority report Kyle
kolinsky and other shows i watch are no
longer on my homepage despite me having
subscriptions for a long time my
homepage is now filled with many things
I don't watch or subscribe to mainly
balanced between parakeets I don't even
know what that is and cardi B I'm so
sorry that this is affecting your show
financially I love your show keep up the
good work
sadly dozens dozens of emails like this
and I as I've said before we know what
the solution is here we've got to
disconnect the programming from being
dependent on ad revenue that that's the
solution I said before I estimate under
1% of my audience funds the show
directly through membership if we can
get from under 1% to 2%
we're in fantastic shape if we can get
to 3% of our audience
supporting us directly we have no more
problems period I mean that's the we're
talking about such small percentages
that going from point 8 percent to 2
percent or 0.8 percent to 3 percent is a
game-changer so I believe this has to be
a wake
call it doesn't have to be this show
okay what I'm telling you is if there
are programs that you like that you want
to see remain independent that you want
to see producing the content they
believe should be produced not what is
going to be monetized by YouTube or
other arbitrary algorithms we need to
support those shows directly if we can
afford to do so with my program the way
to do that is that join pakman.com okay
we have normal prices that I believe are
very reasonable with a pay what you can
afford model starting at $6 a month or
$60.00 per year however I understand
that's a lot of money for many people in
the audience and that's okay we have
discounts available I mean it's just
take the discount if you want it if you
apply the coupon code this is 2020 when
you sign up any membership is reduced by
40% okay I'm going to say something even
further today there is an old coupon
code which we very briefly promoted
which we haven't been promoting but
because the situation is just so
important right now I'm gonna give it
out today if you want a 50% discount
okay which will get you down to $3 a
month or $30 a year 30 dollars a year is
like 280 a month okay the coupon code
half 19h a lf1
by 50% we're not talking about a lot of
money but this is the way that we fix
this problem
it's it's the way it's the most direct
way and that's why I'm asking for your
support
please share this video using the share
button on YouTube because it's really
important to get news of what's going on
to as many people as possible and yes I
know people are saying hey David did you
hear about X youtuber who's seeing the
same thing who's on the right maybe did
you hear about X youtuber on the Y
youtuber on the Left who's seeing the
same thing yes I'm in touch with a lot
of those folks and we are talking about
this a lot there's no question about it
there has been a ton of press around
Donald Trump's interview with George
Stephanopoulos on ABC news last week and
I already talked a lot about the
politics in the interview the things
Trump said the incorrect allegations and
assertions that Donald Trump made but
there is a 4747 second section of this
interview
that isn't getting nearly the discussion
it deserves which exposes what I
consider to be the real Donald Trump the
truly terrible toxic bad person that
Donald Trump is to be around and this is
kind of buried in part three of the
interview with George Stephanopoulos
what ABC News did is divide the
interview into three parts the first two
I think are each about 12 or 13 minutes
long and part three at least as I saw it
divided up on the ABC News YouTube
channel is much shorter and in part
three George Stephanopoulos is pressing
Donald Trump about his financial
disclosures and Trump is going into one
of these nonsense talking point rants
that he gaves which are never really
answers they often contradict the thing
he says in the first 15 seconds
contradicts the thing he says in the
second 15 seconds he says he won't
release his financial disclosure but he
hopes that eventually people see it even
though he could release at any time and
in the midst of Donald Trump talking
about this there's a coffin the
background okay and Trump stops talking
and the look on his face changes he
looks all of a sudden rabid and he says
he wants to do it over again because his
chief of staff is coughing in the
background now it's actually pretty
interesting that ABC News even included
this in the final cut because Trump
asked for it to be redone and then he
redoes his answer with equally
nonsensical talking points but when you
hear him talking about the cough in the
background when you see the look on his
face when you hear the vitriol and the
toxicity in his voice Trump sounds like
he thinks the people around him
including his chief of staff who coughed
are just worthless barely human forms of
life and this is the Trump we've thought
was the real Trump from all of the
reports about him from former employees
former campaign officials from reports
about his relationships with his own
families his own family members and with
his various mistresses and women he's
had affairs with the audio tells us a
lot it's better if you're watching this
so that you also see the anger and the
disgust on Donald Trump's face someone
coughing this is a brief appearance of
the real Donald Trump which I believe
Trump didn't think would ultimately be
published as part of the interview but
still if you're even
to treat people like this in front of
George Stephanopoulos and an entire ABC
crew plus your own staff and security
how is he behaving in more truly private
settings take a look at these 47 seconds
of video much much bigger much much
better than anybody thereafter my
financial statement the Senate they'd
like to get my financial statement at
some point I hope they get it you're
gonna turn it over no at some point I
might but at some point I hope they get
it because it's safe enough it's a
fantastic financial statement it's a
fantastic financial statement and let's
do that over he's coughing in the middle
of my answer yeah okay I don't like that
you know your chief of staff
you gonna cough please just get just to
change the shot I'm sorry okay you want
to do that a little differently then so
at some point so at some point I look
forward to frankly I want I'd like to
have people see my financial statement
there's a literal Jekyll and Hyde
transformation that you see on Donald
Trump's face when Mulvaney coughs Trump
stops playing the character that he's
playing in the interview and he becomes
the real Trump and by the way what does
it even mean that it's a financial
statement that's fantastic and if it's
so good why isn't Trump going to publish
it that that's a whole other discussion
to be had but this is the real Trump he
is a terrible person he has no empathy
for anyone period he's horrible to be
around he's self-centered to the
absolute maximum he could have indicated
that he didn't like the COFF and he
wanted to do it over by saying sorry
George one second Mick are you okay and
done it over again any non narcissist
would have behaved completely
differently here and this is one of the
most disturbing parts of the interview
as Donald Trump sits there with pure
malice in his eyes for his own chief of
staff it was actually suggested and this
makes it even more interesting it was
suggested that Trump was making such a
fool of himself with his answer on this
financial disclosure issue to George
Stephanopoulos that Mulvaney might have
coughed deliberately to ruin what Trump
was saying because it was so stupid and
dumb in order to give Trump and out and
if that's true and we don't know if it
is that would actually make Donald
Trump's treatment of Mulvaney even more
stunning even though it wouldn't
surprise me that Donald Trump simply
wouldn't be smart enough to realize that
Mulvaney was trying to help Trump and
trying to get him out of trouble in any
case that's the real Donald Trump that
is the real Donald Trump who is an
absolute disgrace and nightmare to work
for exposed very briefly in 47 seconds
of audio and video I encourage you to
watch the entire interview because the
whole thing is a pathetic gong show
there are few attacks on the freedom of
an independent press that are more
chilling than threatening reporters with
prison time and we just learned that
Donald Trump has done exactly that this
is truly a disturbing act that it would
be great to see it cross party lines it
should scare every single one of us and
that includes Republicans and Democrats
and it would be great to see both
Republicans and Democrats that are our
elected officials call this out but in
the world in which we exist today of
haphazard and knee-jerk defenses of
anything that Donald Trump says or does
I don't think we're going to see it okay
you might remember that Donald Trump
once had this letter that Kim jong-un
sent him I think he might have called it
a beautiful letter or something like
that Donald Trump had reporters in the
room at that time and he may have asked
to go off the record in terms of the
contents or maybe not and he held up the
letter and from what we have learned so
far a reporter from Time magazine held
up his camera to take a picture and
Donald Trump said and it's sort of
confusing and muddled and erratic like a
lot of what Donald Trump says but what
Trump said according to the transcript
is excuse me under Section two well you
can go to prison instead because if you
use if you use the photograph you took
of the letter that I gave you and time
tries to continue talking about the
topic of the interview do you believe
that people should be and Trump
interrupts interrupts confidentially I
didn't give it to you to take
photographs of it so don't play that
game with me let me just tell you
something you take a look time says I'm
sorry mr. president
were you threatening me with prison time
and Trump says well I told you the
following I told you you can look at
this off the record
that doesn't mean you take out your
camera and start taking pictures of it
okay so I hope you don't have a picture
of it I know you were very quick to pull
it out even you were surprised to see
that you can't do that stuff so go have
fun with your story because I'm sure it
will be the 28th horrible story I have
in Time magazine because I never I mean
ha it's incredible
with all I've done and the success I've
had the way that Time magazine writes is
absolutely incredible
fascinatingly this riled him up so much
that he then went into a huge rant about
no collusion no obstruction as a result
of a photographer taking a picture it is
just so incredible to read a transcript
of Donald Trump scolding a reporter for
taking a picture of something that Trump
gave confidentially which he doesn't
even understand the meaning of while he
has given up secrets from allies to
Russians in the Oval Office I mean it's
a jarring juxtaposition of what Trump
says and what Trump does and it's really
important to understand here when Trump
says he gave something confidentially
confidential is a classification of
documents you can't just yell out this
is confidential or you know this pen is
top-secret and make it so and it's also
really important to understand that it's
Trump who shouldn't be showing things to
people who don't have the correct
clearances and more importantly Trump
and his aides remember have bragged
endlessly about how Trump can declassify
anything he wants by showing it to
whoever he wants if Trump shows someone
the picture then he has decided that
it's okay for them to see it it's also
really funny that Trump mentioned
section two and then he seemed to
realize he didn't know what he was
talking about let's put the transcript
back up on the screen for a moment Trump
started to say excuse me under Section
two and then he kind of went away from
that said well you can go to prison
instead I guess he means article two of
the Constitution or maybe section 2 of
article two during the same confused
interview he seemed to be using the term
section two an article to kind of
interchangeably like maybe they're the
same thing and he doesn't know what he's
talking about article
has two sections of the Constitution
section one establishes basically how
the President and vice-president are to
be elected and served four-year terms
section 2 of article 2 talks about the
president being the head of the
executive branch of government and the
commander-in-chief of the Armed Forces
who on earth knows what Donald Trump was
talking about when he mentioned section
2 and then article 2 but at least at
some point he seemed to have the
presence of mind to realize he doesn't
actually know what the hell he's talking
about
this is Trump though okay when he was in
private business he would threaten to
sue anyone in business that he didn't
like that was a strategy and based on
what we know from Michael Cohen his
former personal attorney that was a
pretty effective strategy siccing
Michael Cohen the attack dog on people
with threats of lawsuits was a pretty
effective way to get compliance from the
people he wanted to get compliance from
now he's threatening people with prison
because he's President of the United
States it is truly chilling to see him
waive prison time around to reporters in
this way and I know that there will be
crumpets who see this and say David it
was a vague threat he's generally
talking about prison freedom of the
press is one of the most important of
speech freedoms that we have in this
country and a president threatening or
even mentioning prison to a reporter in
this way is unheard of except in
extremely authoritarian dictatorial
circles and that is exactly what Donald
Trump aspires to and that's why this is
so chilling and dangerous let me know
what you think make sure you're
following me on instagram at david
pakman make sure while you're there you
follow the show on instagram at david
pakman show
there is a conservative a british
politician who rung a Greenpeace
activists neck when she interrupted a
speech in the United Kingdom a few days
ago and I'm gonna set this up for you
mark field is a member of parliament or
an MP as they are known in the United
Kingdom he's 54 years old he's a member
of the Conservative Party in the UK also
known as the Tories and a few days ago
Chancellor Philip Hammond was
giving a speech about brexit at what's
called the bankers and merchants dinner
greenpeace greenpeace is the climate
activist organization they sent 40
volunteers today to this event to try to
interfere with the speech and get
attention for climate change one woman
was walking around there as part of this
protest and mark fields got up and
grabbed her and pushed her and then
wrung her neck some might almost call it
strangling from behind although i don't
know that that's the right term in this
particular case and there is video so
immediately the question is is this
treatment too rough for someone that
seems to be one of 40 peaceful
protesters some have argued she could
have had a gun hard to imagine from the
dress she was wearing that she had a gun
not to mention both of her hands were
full of items which would make it quite
difficult to even get a gun out of her
purse if that's what she had and where
she had it Fields is saying his reaction
was quote instinctive given the
circumstances and Fields has since
apologized to the woman there are other
MPs calling for this guy to go Labour MP
Tanya Antonio at sea says quote no one
who reacts like this to a peaceful
protest should be sitting in our
Parliament Liberal Democrat MP chuka
emunah says that the actions are totally
unacceptable
former Tory MP Sarah Wollaston says it
was quote absolutely shameful a male MP
marching a woman out of a room by her
neck Labour Minister Don Butler tweeted
this is horrific mark field must
immediately be suspended or sacked
bottom line a woman in a ball gown with
high heels holding a cell phone in a
small purse is not the threat that
instinctively was apparently what went
to mark fields mind here it's extremely
difficult to buy that now some people
are making this a man versus woman issue
saying oh you're only upset because the
protester was a woman but it would have
been totally fine if the protester had
been a man there is no question that
gender is a factor here I would argue
it's a reasonable factor but beyond that
a sitting MP putting his hands on a
member of the public's throat is now
what we're
bending I got an email from a viewer
saying the way this guy reacted his
entire posture his entire demeanor
during this is of a classic domestic
abuser I would not argue that this guy
is a domestic abuser absent evidence
that he is a domestic of you abuser what
I do believe is that this is a level of
aggression that did come naturally to me
to it to him in the moment and I can
also tell you that in the United States
far less aggressive physical attacks
than this often lead to people being
charged with battery so I want to hear
from you what do you think about this if
you've been listening to the podcast a
radio show and you you didn't see the
video that we just played for a video
audience find the video online and let
me know what you think of it we've
gotten away from using the term [ __ ]
as an insult or in casual language in
modern American society because it's not
good for people who actually suffer from
Down syndrome it's not good for their
families and their friends it's not good
to use that term about people with other
cognitive and intellectual limitations
but this apparently hasn't stopped the
Iranian president from seemingly
seriously claiming that Donald Trump
suffers from mental retardation this was
during a live televised address at least
partially commenting on the new US
sanctions against Iran the president
Donald Trump has announced Donald Trump
of course imposing these new sanctions
on Iran the Iranian president Hassan
rouhani calling the sanctions outrageous
and idiotic and adding that quote the
White House is afflicted by mental
retardation and does not know what to do
as translated and reported by The
Associated Press from the native Farsi
there are other translations that are a
little bit softer suggesting that the
terms cognitive limitations are
something along those lines were
actually what was used a disagreement
about exactly how it should be
translated from Farsi now almost as
importantly but maybe not quite
pragmatically the Iranian president also
saying quote you sanctioned the foreign
minister simultaneously with a request
for talks and this goes to the erratic
and sort of a very strange nature
of what Donald Trump has been doing with
regard to Iran that I talked about in
the first segment at which we discussed
the undeniable reality that in the end
when you put the bluster and the
rhetoric aside Donald Trump's actual
actions are going mostly in line with
what a Vladimir Putin with Russia as the
top priority would want Donald Trump to
do if four years ago I had told you that
in 2019 world leaders would be calling
each other Rocketman and mentally
[ __ ] I wouldn't have believed it
maybe some in our audience would but
here we are in 2019 and there's this
hilarious double standard among trumpets
who all of a sudden now are pretending
that mentally [ __ ] is outside the
lines and an inappropriate way to talk
about Donald Trump when they've spent
the last almost four years calling
anyone that disagrees with them a [ __ ]
world politics under Obama let's
generate productive dialogue for the
mutual betterment of all humans on earth
world politics under Trump who is the
biggest [ __ ] or cuck or low energy
person and truly to take this seriously
for a second because it is serious
people with Down's syndrome often care
about others and express significant
empathy Donald Trump actually seems to
be completely lacking that like aside
from this being meant as an apparent
insult most people with intellectual
disabilities seem to be better people
than Donald Trump
who exhibits cruelty his bullying nature
greediness complete self-absorption in
every way and Trump meanwhile responding
that Iran the Iranian president's mom is
gay or something like that I'm kidding
but seriously Trump is actually unstable
enough that calling him mentally
[ __ ] could actually trigger a war it
could actually trigger military action
remember that Donald Trump just a few
days ago approved the strike on Iran
without even considering civilian
casualties later he was told what they
would be I believe about a hundred and
fifty and then he cancelled the attack
or at least he claims that's the reason
why this has the potential to completely
derail Trump and meanwhile the Trump
administration is still preaching it has
leveraged a
the Iran deal which Trump backed out of
John Bolton Donald Trump's national
security adviser again is saying all
options remain on the table with Iran if
they exceed the uranium enrichment limit
that is put in place by the 2015 Iran
nuclear deal
Trump pulled us out of the deal the
United States has no authority to
enforce that deal because Trump pulled
us out of it you can have the discussion
and we have had it already by the way
you can argue there are still other
signatories to the Iran nuclear deal
that have not backed out the UK Germany
our European allies and maybe you could
say they have the leverage to enforce or
demand the enforcement of that deal
although the United States has made it
quite difficult for them to actually do
that the United States has given away
all credibility and leverage to demand
adhering to that deal given that we
pulled out of it and it is absolutely
pathetic that even on corporate media
some Trump lackeys flunkies flax flax or
flunkies Blackie's I think that's going
to be another Urban Dictionary term
Trump flunkies are being allowed to say
this that hey Iran still has to stick to
that deal that's going to be up to our
allies to decide whether they want to or
can't even enforce that after the United
States has departed from the deal no one
in the Trump administration should even
be mentioning the requirements of the
Iran deal because we are no longer part
of that deal if you disagree with me let
me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
okay I'm just now caught up on the
different Sunday show interviews that
happened this past Sunday one was an
interview with Bernie Sanders on CBS's
Face the Nation Bernie Sanders is
running for president in 2020 he's
currently a senator and there was a
moment where the interviewer Margaret
Brennan truly embarrassed herself in
trying to sort of play the tough devil's
advocate or giving Bernie Sanders a
gotcha question and it completely
imploded in utter total embarrassment
when the topic of Iran came up now
before I play that part I'm just gonna
play the first 20 seconds of this
interview which will immediately give
you a sense of just how dumb and cringy
this interview was listen to the strange
sort of
I don't even know what to call it just
the entire demeanor of interviewer
Margaret Brennan is bizarre towards
Bernie here's a setup of how this
interview started thank you very much
for making time my pleasure
you've been called an existential threat
to the Democratic Party how much
resistance within the party do you face
well firstly I got to figure out what
this existential threat actually means
but what it came from is Third Way which
is the corporate wing of the Democratic
Party so Bernie does a good job of
slowing it all down at every opportunity
during the interview reducing the
hysteria but then they get to the topic
of Iran and Bernie starts correctly
criticizing Donald Trump's completely
erratic action on Iran over the weekend
which we covered where we were bombing
Iran and then we called off the bombing
of Iran and Margaret Brennan starts
playing I don't know if it's again just
playing a weird devil's advocate or
playing a semantic game when Bernie
starts talking about war with Iran where
she says well war I mean you know it was
a limited strike and Bernie Sanders
takes none of it and he accurately and
precisely and concisely and pithily
destroys that argument I want to ask you
about Iran was president Trump's
decision this week to call off that
strike the right one see it's like
somebody setting a fire to a basket full
of paper and then putting it out he
helped create the crisis and then he
stopped the attacks the idea that we're
looking at a president in the United
States who number one thinks that a war
with Iran is something that might be
good for this country he was just doing
a limited strike well just a limited
scope well I'm sorry I just didn't know
that it's okay to simply attack another
country with bombs just a limited so
that's an act of warfare this is a great
example of the different standards that
are applied to the actions of the United
States versus the actions of other
countries by Americans okay and this is
one of the things where it's so
refreshing you know I have family in
Argentina I was born there I have family
in France and in different places and
when I talked to them it
it's refreshing to talk to people who
are not applying a different standard to
the United States than to other
countries because think about it if any
other country launched a so-called
limited strike of any kind against the
United States on an American military
base abroad even everyone would be on
the same page in the US it's an act of
warfare Pearl Harbor in a sense it was a
limited strike on a US military base the
double standard has to stop and I guess
I sort of get the idea that Margaret
Brennan
is trying to play devil's advocate here
and be the tough interviewer who's going
to hold Bernie Sanders to account but
she's choosing all the wrong spots it's
very ignorant the way she's trying to do
it if North Korea did a limited strike
in South Korea would that be a limited
strike or would it be an act of warfare
I think we all know the answer in some
sense 9/11 was a limited strike on a
very specific section of New York City
and Washington DC there was total
consensus that it was an act of war
which was then used to justify not one
but two wars the war in Iraq which was
completely unrelated to 9/11 and an
escalation of the war in Afghanistan so
I'm fine debating any of these foreign
policy decisions on the merits whether
it's Iran Syria Venezuela China Cuba
policy Russia there are serious
conversations to be had about any of
those countries and I'm not just saying
militarily but in many different ways
there are legitimate debates about what
US foreign policy should be and how it
has work they're not worth in the past
but there is this very dangerous and
disturbing tendency for Americans in a
sort of bubble to shrug off the actions
of the American military when if we
reverse the situation these would be
obvious acts of war which the same
people would say oh wow
that was an act of war the u.s. must now
retaliate against this act of war so I
don't believe that it's a useful type of
devil's advocacy by the interviewer
Margaret Brennan I'm curious to hear
what you think about it I understand
playing devil's advocate I do it on this
show but I try to do it in a thoughtful
way where it makes sense I don't just
pick ran
semantics devil's advocacy and throw it
out there to make it seem like I'm
challenging the guests I want to be
challenging the guests in a way that is
substantive and critically useful it's
merely sort of manufacturing a context
in which we can then shrug off our own
aggressive acts of violence what
Margaret Brennan is doing here it should
be denounced and this is not the type of
cover we want to provide to our foreign
policy apparatus particularly not when
you have a completely clueless and
ignorant president in Donald Trump
surrounded by people who are almost
completely off the rails unhinged when
it comes to foreign policy people like
john bolton and steven miller and others
that are surrounding Donald Trump it
straight up irresponsible to do this
bogus gotcha foe devil's advocacy that
was done here good for Bernie though in
absolutely destroying it make sure you
follow me on instagram at david pakman
I've got some great behind-the-scenes
stuff from the studio people curious
about what things look like here and
lots of other great stuff follow me
there at David Pakman and follow the
show on instagram at david pakman show
there is a new sexual assault allegation
against Donald Trump in addition to the
what is it twelve or sixteen that
already exists and this is a really bad
one this is an allegation of rape now I
think because of the creeping
normalization that we've experienced in
the United States under Donald Trump for
the last couple of years it's crazy I
have to mention this but even one
instance of something like this for
Barack Obama would have been a 24/7
scandal on corporate and right-wing
media for weeks at least but it was
almost completely ignored by the Sunday
morning talk shows and got relatively
little coverage over the weekend first
of all we are talking here about
magazine advice columnist and former
Miss Indiana University II Jean Carol
who has accused Donald Trump of
attacking her and raping her at a New
York department store in the late 1990s
the Carroll says that she ran into Trump
in the fall of 95 or spring of 96 at the
Bergdorf Goodman department store in New
York City where she says he at
actor in one of the dressing rooms
claims that Donald Trump pressured her
to try on lingerie grabbed her arm to
pull her towards the rest at dressing
room and then I will read her quote and
I warn you it is extremely graphic and
disturbing quote the moment the dressing
room door is closed he lunges at me
pushes me against the wall hitting my
head quite badly and puts his mouth
against my lips I am so shocked I shove
him back and start laughing again he
seizes both my arms and pushes me up
against the wall a second time and as I
become aware of how large he is he holds
me against the wall with his shoulder
and jams his hand under my coat dress
and pulls down my tights I am astonished
by what I'm about to write I keep
laughing
the next moment still wearing correct
business attire shirt tie suit jacket
overcoat he opens the overcoat unzips
his pants and forcing his fingers around
my private area thrusts his penis
halfway or completely I'm not certain
inside me this is an allegation of rape
she's alleging that she was raped by
Donald Trump now Trump is denied it says
he has no idea who the woman is a
picture has since been published of
Donald Trump with the accuser Jean Carol
and close to total silence about this on
the big5 Sunday talk shows ABC CBS CNN
MSNBC and Fox all have these Sunday talk
shows Mike Pence was interviewed Bernie
Sanders was interviewed no mentions of
the new rape allegations against Donald
Trump so a couple things to talk about
here first of all if the corporate media
were all as liberally biased as Donald
Trump and Republicans and Trump's
sycophants claimed corporate media to be
liberally biased this would have been a
topic of discussion yesterday period
number two the hypocrisy of Republicans
who uniformly jump behind any allegation
no matter who makes it against Democrats
like for example against Bill Clinton
Juanita Broderick in 1999 or whoever
else they now are ignoring more than a
dozen allegations against Donald Trump
if this is mere politics
why couldn't some of the allegations
against Bill Clinton have been given the
same benefit of the doubt as they
providing through the allegations
against Donald Trump but in any other
presidency it's really important to
understand this would be front page news
non-stop period now I would also be
curious to know asking all the people
who hated Barack Obama and thought he
was the worst person in the world that
he had committed all sorts of crimes
that he was in some cases a
shape-shifting Antichrist that he was
planning to declare martial law and
suspend the 2016 election to try to stay
in power indefinitely why is it that no
one thought to concoct sexual assault
allegations against Barack Obama I mean
not only are there not sexual assault
allegations against Barack Obama there
are not even what we could call
political sexual assault allegations
that are against Barack Obama and for
those who say this is a tactic that the
left uses against Republicans fake
sexual assault allegations why were
there no sexual assault allegations
against Republican president george w
bush so the point is it's not based in
fact to claim every president has sexual
assault accusers and they're widely
understood to be fake and attempts to
take down presidents know most
presidents do not have sexual assault
allegations levied against them and
Donald Trump having 12 or 15 or 80 I
don't even know what the number is at
this point including remember child rape
allegations which I have covered but
have not received nearly enough
attention this is different okay it is
not even remotely reasonable to say
presidents they always have all sorts of
sexual assault allegations against them
no Barack Obama didn't george w bush
didn't now as far as the corporate media
coverage is this not getting coverage
because even the reporters and the media
have become totally numb to and
desensitized the donald trump's
treatment of women is it that they have
calculated that there is little upside
to covering the 17th or the 19th or
whatever allegation because the first 12
or 15 or 17 didn't get traction what do
you think is going on here is what's
going on as
shocking and disturbing as that or is
there something else that is preventing
this from getting coverage